[Music]
are you just now getting home wait is
this a walk of shame i mean is it a walk
of shame if i stayed up all night in the
library hooking up with my textbook
wow we are so
different so excited that classes are
finally starting what classes are you
taking i literally don't even know i
just signed up for anything that started
with intro
young stalin could get it
right
dude could have been on riverdale
[Music]
damn she's a lucky lady she's my sister
actually yikes
do not have sex with any of my roommates
she's not used to guys like you you
should have seen the boy who came to
visit her you look like a goat i did
forget my toothbrush put a shirt on
all right this is yours whitney this is
yours
she's good tonight we're gonna rage our
brains out at the anything but close
party i will be making a mini dress made
out of caution tape
and caution i will be showing some ass
meat can you please not say ask me while
we are eating
did you just get a mysterious envelope
it's my invite to kappa's pre-rush
brunch later this afternoon your name is
ashley too i spell it a-s-h-l-e-e
e-i-g-h l-u-y-e i look forward to seeing
you all on sewing sunset one day
you had a one-night stand i know that is
the sexiest thing i've ever heard
you know those girls that are like
confident yeah i hate them me too i just
pretended to be one of them
i still think sex was better when it's
with someone you love and it's an
expression of your commitment
[Music]
people prefer men's sports because we're
better athletes
[Music]
nevertheless
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on in here he's using
makeup to suddenly enhance my banging
body yeah nobody has that many abs it's
impressive right why is there a tan
aspen on our couch what you should be
asking
is why aren't there four
which group of us looks more
approachable the right or the left
the right butts look kinder but i don't
know what i'm basing that on yeah no i
agree ripe rubs for sure
[Music]
you